NOW TO THE  JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE GOT A LOT TO BREAK DOWN
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE HEARD SO FAR.
AND WHEN IS NOW TO DISCUSS IS
FORMER WATERGATE  PROSECUTOR
NICK ACKERMAN, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE LAWYER NICK SCHOLZ AND
RUTH BEEN THE GOT, AUTHOR OF
STRONGMAN. THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING ME.
NICK, THE COMMITTEE HAS
PROMISED THAT THEY WOULD YOU
KNOW, DIRECTLY CONNECT THE
EXTREMIST GROUPS THAT STORMED
THE CAPITOL TO  THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, DID THEY
DELIVER THIS HEARING?
>> THEY DID TO AN EXTENT.
THEY CERTAINLY SHOWED THAT
DONALD TRUMP PUT OUT THE TWEET
ON THE NIGHT, OR EARLY THE
MORNING OF DECEMBER 9th THAT
BASICALLY, RESULTED IN ALL OF
THESE EXTREMIST GROUPS SHOWING
UP ON JANUARY 6th.
THEY SHOWED THAT HE WAS TOTALLY
AWARE OF THE RALLY THAT WAS
GOING ON ON JANUARY 5th, THAT
WAS INVOLVING THE EXTREMIST
GROUPS.
AT ANOTHER LOCATION CLOSE TO
THE WHITE HOUSE, THERE ARE
HINTS ABOUT CALLS FROM PEOPLE
TO ROGER STONE, TO STEVE
BANNON, STEVE BANNON, SPEAKING
TO DONALD TRUMP THE NIGHT OF
JANUARY 5th, AND THEN BASICALLY
SAYING ON HIS PODCAST, THINGS
ARE REALLY GOING TO BE WILD THE
NEXT DAY.
YOU GOT MEADOWS MAKING A CALL
TO ROGER STONE.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE REALLY
TIED IT TOGETHER.
THERE'S LOTS OF CIRCUMSTANTIAL
PROOF THAT DONALD TRUMP KNEW
SOMETHING WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
THAT LAST HEARING THAT WE ARE
GOING TO GET TIED TOGETHER.
>> THE OTHER PIECE OF EVIDENCE
TIED TOGETHER WAS IN THE WAKE
OF THE ATTACKS, RIGHT AFTER IT
HAPPENED, TRUMPS FORMER
CAMPAIGN MANAGER BRAD PARSCALE
SENT A QUOTE SAYING, "TRUMPS
RHETORIC KILLED SOMEONE."
JEN, YOUR TAKE DO YOU FEEL LIKE
THE CONNECTION IS CLEAR?
>> I THINK THE LAST COMMENTS
WERE EXACTLY SPOT ON.
BUT WHAT I THINK, I DON'T THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO GET THAT CLEAR
NEXIS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I THINK THE ONLY WAY TO GET
THAT CLEAR NEXIS IS TO DO THAT
BY WAY OF GRAND JURY PRINT AND
WE ARE ASSUMING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TAKE SET UP.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT CONGRESS
WILL LIKELY MAKE A REFERRAL
OVER TO DOJ, GIVEN SOME OF THE
SINGLES USING TODAY.
>> AND RUTH, WE HEARD YESTERDAY
FROM ONE WITNESS WHO PLEADED
GUILTY ALREADY IN THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION TO DISORDERLY
CONDUCT FOR ILLEGALLY ENTERING
THE CAPITOL THAT DAY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY PLAN TO
GO DOWN THERE.
YOU KNOW, WE WENT BASICALLY TO
SEE THE STOP THE STEAL RALLY,
AND THAT WAS IT.
>> SO WHY DID YOU SIDE TO MARCH
TO THE?
>> WELL, BASICALLY, THE
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW, HE HAD GOT
EVERYBODY RILED UP TO EVERYBODY
TO HEAD DOWN, SO WE BASICALLY
FOLLOWED WHAT HE SAID.
>> HOW SIGNIFICANT WAS THIS
TESTIMONY?
>> VERY, BECAUSE THE CORE, WE
REALLY CAN'T UNDERSTAND JANUARY
6th WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING THE
STRENGTH OF TRUMPS CALLS AND
THE HOLY HAD ON PEOPLE.
AND THIS WAS THE SAME LEADER,
THAT WAS SUMMONED BY HIS LEADER
IN DISTRESS AND HAD THE
ELECTION AND SAID HE WAS
WRONGED.
BUT HE HAD ALSO BEEN USING
RALLIES SINCE 2015 TO
SYSTEMATICALLY CULTIVATE NOT
ONLY EXTREMISTS, AND AS THE
OATH KEEPERS SAID YESTERDAY,
MOVING THE PATH FORWARD AND
MAKING THEM FEEL LEGITIMATE.
REMEMBER HE ALSO CALLED NEO-
NAZIS VERY FINE PEOPLE AND WE
DIDN'T EXPECT THAT FROM A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO ALL THESE DIFFERENT
EXTREMISTS WERE GIVEN KIND OF A
BIG TENT TO FEEL LIKE THEY HAD
A PATH FORWARD, AND WERE
ENCOURAGED IN VIOLENCE.
BUT THE VIOLENCE IN PARTICULAR
WERE CULTIVATING THIS KIND OF
EMOTIONAL TRAINING TO BE
VIOLENT AND CONSIDER VIOLENCE
AS PATRIOTIC AND I THINK THAT
IS WHY BRAD PARSCALE,  WHO WAS
NOT ONLY HIS CAMPAIGN MANAGER
BUT OVERSAW THE DIGITAL PART
AND THAT TESTIMONY, THE FIRST
ONE YOU MENTIONED, HE TALKED
ABOUT HOW HE WAS GRATIFIED FROM
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT IS WHY BRAD PARSCALE  SAID
THAT RHETORIC KILLS COMING FROM
TRUMP.
>> AND NICK YOU MENTIONED THIS
OFF THE TOP, A LOT OF PEOPLE
WENT TO DC BECAUSE OF THAT
INITIAL TWEET FROM TRUMP.
HE SAID BE THERE, BE WILD.
NOWHERE DID TRUMP EXPLICITLY SAY
,  STORM THE CAPITOL.
BUT IT SEEMS SO MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT TOOK ALL OF THIS AS
TRUMP GIVING THEM DIRECT IS .
IT WAS JUST HOURS AFTER THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PROUD BOYS AND
OATH KEEPERS REPORTEDLY DECIDED
TO FORM AN ALLIANCE.
AS A PROSECUTOR, THAT IS BAD
ENOUGH.
>> NO, YOU NEED MORE EVIDENCE.
BUT YOU GOT TO KEEP IN MIND
THERE WERE REALLY TWO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE THERE.
THERE WAS THE GROUP OF PEOPLE
LIKE STEPHEN AYRES, WHO
BASICALLY FOLLOWED WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID.
THEY WENT THERE BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO RUN.
BUT THERE WAS THIS OTHER GROUP
THAT WAS THE OATH KEEPERS AND
THE PROUD BOYS THAT WERE THERE
VERY PURPOSELY,  IT WAS
PREMEDITATED, IT WAS SET UP FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY GO INTO THE
CAPITOL  AT DIFFERENT SPOTS TO
BREAK IN THERE, TO CAUSE THE
MAYHEM IN THE VIOLENCE THE GOAL
OF WHICH, WAS TO STOP THE BOAT
CAMP COUNT ON THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF
WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE
LIKE STEPHEN AYRES , WERE
SIMPLE SIMPLY A FOIL TO THEM TO
CREATE MORE MAYHEM ON THE SPOT
TO GIVE THE PROUD BOYS, AND THE
OATH KEEPERS THE ROOM TO GET IN.
>> JEN, FOR THE FIRST TIME WE
FINALLY HEARD FROM FORMER WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL PAT CIPOLLONE.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE ANTICIPATED
TESTIMONY, HOW DO YOU THINK HIS
TESTIMONY WAS?
>> I THINK IT WAS KEY AND THAT
HE CONFIRMED A LOT OF THINGS
THAT CASSIE HUTCHINSON SAID.
THERE IS NO REAL BOMBSHELL
THERE.
BUT CERTAINLY VALUE BECAUSE HE
WAS ABLE TO CONFIRM AND
CORROBORATE SOME OF HIS
TESTIMONY OF OTHER WITNESSES,
WHICH WAS THE KEY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO, I DO THINK, I WENT
BACK TO WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER, YOU KNOW THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION CERTAINLY, YOU
KNOW THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
TAKEN HUGE HITS IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION ON THIS THING.
IT REMAINS TO SEE THE SCENE,
WHERE THE TAKES THE HIT IN THE
COURT OF LAW.
I THINK LARRY IS RIGHT, WE NEED
TO HAVE MORE EVIDENCE IN ORDER
TO MOVE FORWARD.
>> NICK, STEVE BANNON WAS ALSO
PART OF HIS HEARING.
YOU BROUGHT UP HIS PODCAST THAT
WAS ON JANUARY 5th, WHEN HE
SAID THIS.
>> ALL IS GOING TO BREAK LOOSE
TOMORROW.
JUST UNDERSTAND THIS.
ALL IS GOING TO BREAK LOOSE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN LIKE
YOU THINK IT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
OKAY?
IT IS GOING TO BE  QUITE
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFERENT AND
ALL I AM GOING TO SAY IS STRAP
IN.
>> YES, WE PLAYED THAT BEFORE,
YES WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE.
BUT NOW WE KNOW SO MUCH MORE.
MINUTES BEFORE HE SAID THAT ON
AIR, HE SPOKE TO THEN-PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY SPOKE FOR 11 MINUTES,
ACCORDING TO WHITE HOUSE PHONE
LOGS.
AND THIS WEEK WE KNOW THAT
BANNON HAS SAID HE IS WILLING
TO PUBLIC THE TESTIFY.
IF YOU ARE THE COMMITTEE WHAT
DO YOU DO?
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD TAKE HIS
TESTIMONY FOR THEY SHOULD TAKE
IT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PUT THEM OUT
ON PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT AWAY,
BECAUSE HE IS JUST GOING TO TRY
TO PLAY THE COMMITTEE.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO USE IT AS
A PR STUNT, AND HE IS GOING TO
USE IT TO TRY AND RAISE A
DEFENSE IN HIS CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
SO THE COMMITTEE HAS TO BE VERY
CAREFUL HOW THEY TAKE THAT
TESTIMONY.
BUT THEY SHOULD TAKE IT.
AT A MINIMUM, THE WORST THAT
HAPPENS IS THE GUYS GOING TO
PERJURE HIMSELF AND HE WILL
WIND UP IN ANOTHER CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
>> JIM, THE PANEL'S VICE CHAIR,
LIZ CHENEY ENDED YESTERDAY'S
PANEL SAYING TRUMP TRY TO
CONTACT A WITNESS WHO HAS NOT
YET APPEARED BEFORE THE MEETING
THESE HEARINGS.
SHE SAID THE COMMITTEE REFERRED
THAT TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME THE
COMMITTEE MENTIONED DOT
INVOLVEMENT DURING A HEARING.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE
SIGNIFICANCE, DO YOU THINK THIS
WAS ABOUT THE COMMITTEE SENDING
A BROADER MESSAGE?
>> I THINK IT IS ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE, LOOK THERE BEEN A
NUMBER OF THREATS THAT HAVE COME
DOWN TO WITNESSES FROM UNKNOWN
FOLKS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE, WE
DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS ANYONE
DIRECTING THEM.
BUT YOU KNOW, CONTACT WITH A
WITNESS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN TAKING
SERIOUSLY. NO SURPRISE THAT ANY
CONTACT WITH A WITNESS, THEY
ARE GOING TO SEND OVER TO DOJ
TO LOOK INTO.
NO SURPRISE THERE TALL.
AND AS FAR AS BANNON'S
TESTIMONY GOES, WE HAVE TO BE
MINDFUL THAT IF THEY DO THAT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, THERE IS
SOME POLITICAL RISK THERE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN PUSHING
EVERYONE OUT IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THEY TRIED TO GET PAT CIPOLLONE
TO DO IT IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS LIVE AND NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU  ARE GOING TO DRAW
BACK BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT STEVE BANNON IS SAYING,
YOU ARE FREE TO MAKE A MOCKERY
OF THE PROCESS.
THEY NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR
IT, BE AGGRESSIVE AND TAKE HIS
TESTIMONY ON AIR SO YOU CAN
MAINTAIN THAT CREDIBILITY ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
>> RUTH, THE OTHER COMMITTEE
TESTIMONY, FORMER OATH KEEPER
AFFILIATE.
HOW WE CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT
THE CURRENT THREAT?
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED, BECAUSE
THE GOP, WHICH REALLY IS
BECOMING AN EXTREMIST ENTITY IS
UNREPENTANT.
ON JANUARY 7th, WHEN THEY DID
NOT DENOUNCE, THEY COULD HAVE
THROWN TRUMP TO THE WOLVES, HE
WAS SO TOXIC, AND INSTEAD THEY
DOUBLE DOWN.
AND WHAT IS COMING OUT IS HOW
THIS CULTIVATION OF EXTREMISTS
THAT THE OATH KEEPERS AND ALL
THIS OTHER KIND OF EXTREMISTS,
YOU COULD THINK OF THEM AS AN
EMERGING PAIR MILLIE MILITARY
WING. AND THEY WOULD DO IT
AGAIN TOMORROW, MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE.
AND THAT IS WHY I WANT TO SAY,
HAVING STUDIED UNFORTUNATE
DESTRUCTIONS OF DEMOCRACIES ALL
OVER THE WORLD THAT THE FACT
THEY ARE HAVING THESE HEARINGS
AT ALL MAKES ME SO PROUD TO
LIVE IN A DEMOCRACY.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE
HEARINGS IN MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THE INVESTIGATORS
AND THE WITNESSES WH